mobilisation nationale aujourd'hui à la
mémoire d'ilan halimi à paris cent mille
manifestants sont attendus pour cette
marche contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme
la présence du front national et du
mouvement pour la france suscite la
polémique
l annonce de leur participation le mrap
a décidé de se retirer jean françois
feer et à bagneux jeudi ils étaient 350
à défiler dans la mémoire d'ilan halimi
cet après midi à paris ils devraient
être plus de 100000 parmi eux des
responsables politiques notamment du
front national depuis un certain nombre
de mois il ya une montée d'un certain
antisémitisme les directement à une
migration
moi j'ai au moins le courage de le dire
ce que personne n'a le courage de faire
colère des organisateurs
ils n'ont annoncé ils empêcheront le fn
de manifester à leurs côtés les
autorités qui dirigent le front national
ont été condamnés à plusieurs reprises
pour des faits relevant soit du racisme
anti-arabe choix de l'antisémitisme
antijuifs la présence cet après-midi du
souverainiste philippe de villiers
dérange elle aussi mais elle est
acceptée son parti rappelle le crif n'a
jamais été condamné pour propos racistes
conséquence le mrap entre autres
associations ne se joindra pas au
cortège toutes les tendances politiques
elles seront représentées le parti
communiste a confirmé sa participation
par mille